Sí.
Cuando miras la capacidad actual, creo que es
también una pregunta muy importante plantearse:
¿cuál es la hoja de ruta? ¿Cuánto
mejores son estos sistemas
y cuánto más complejos
van a ser los circuit que podamos ejecutar?
Para eso hemos desarrollado una métrica muy importante
llamada volumen cuántico.
A veces puedes leer o escuchar en la prensa popular
el número de qubits, ya sabes,
como medida de progreso.
Te digo directamente que
el simple número de qubits en la máquina no es una
buena medida de progreso.
El progreso debe medirse por
el nivel de complejidad del circuit que puedes ejecutar.
Los qubits en estas buenas máquinas no son perfectos hoy en día:
tienen errores introducidos por el acoplamiento del
sistema con el mundo exterior.
El verdadero poder de estos qubits,
el entrelazamiento y esas propiedades,
es también lo que los hace a la vez poderosos
y delicados ante la interacción
y conexión con el mundo exterior.
Así que necesitas reducir la tasa de errores
mientras aumentas el número de qubits.
Eso es lo que se muestra aquí:
lo que realmente quieres hacer es moverte en diagonal,
y el volumen cuántico es una medida que incorpora
ambas métricas y algunas consideraciones adicionales clave.